everyone welcome back to the game spud
stayed here at e3 2017 joining myself
and Dave is Justin here to talk about
skullenbones it's absolutely surprised
that you pass us press conference oh
that's great I mean we worked on the
game you know in total secrecy and it's
just such a relief to be able to share
the game with the world get people
excited about being a pirate in the
Indian Ocean during the Golden Age of
piracy ironic though the one year the
game that involves pirate ships is one
of the ones that had the fewest leaks
yeah I mean the yeah we stayed sturdy
stayed strong uh so what I think was
really cool is that the the the pirate
section the pirate we start over
completely lost air so sorry that's
right I get my joke you can and will
laugh again
hey everyone welcome back to the games
foot stage here at e3 2017 joining Dave
and myself is Justin Barron here to talk
about skull and bones welcome absolutely
thanks very much it's exciting to be
able to share our game skull and bones
with the world now yeah and it was the
big surprise III at the Ubisoft III
press conference right yeah it's a it's
a big relief for us to you know finally
be able to let the cat out of the bag
and share our game and our hard work
with the rest of the world the ironic
the game with pirate ships in is one
that had the fewest leaks yeah we stayed
sturdy we stayed strong but you know the
Ubisoft Singapore this is our first time
leading a triple-a IP and for us this is
just the best feeling to see the
reaction and see people really
passionate about a pirate game and the
game that we're trying to build I mean
so obviously the the naval warfare was a
huge part of Sasson speed for Black Flag
and is that where scholars came from
that it was it was kind of like you guys
saw how much the community really loved
that aspect to the game and decided yeah
let's make this a full thing well I
think this is the game we always wanted
to make you know being a pirate is a
very base fantasy it's something all of
us want to do as kids and then you add
that to the like you said the legacy of
working on both the AC missions and
Assassin's Creed 3 and the naval
openable content and missions and
Assassin's Creed 4 Black Flag and the
water technology we've developed at
Ubisoft Singapore as well as the
competencies we've developed with Ghost
Recon phantoms the online shooter so
Skull and Bones is an online service we
want to combine our skills and really
make the best pirate game that's ever
been made yeah you've changed from for
going from Black Flag that was in the
Caribbean and now in the Indian Ocean
how is that kind of change the aesthetic
in the start of the game
well the assets that you see the things
that you're seeing now are set in
Madagascar they set off the coast of the
Mozambique Channel and there's some
familiarity to this exotic location but
when you think about the fishbowl of the
Caribbean the small theatre that it
represents and the the western coast of
the US what we're trying to build is a
tapestry a canvas that players can tell
their own story across a much bigger
environment the Indian Ocean itself is
rich with history of pirates and even
home to the one of the largest heist
that's ever taken place in history with
Henry Avery taking down the Ganges so
why which led to the first worldwide
manhunt you know in terms of Parsi so
it's a great setting for us to really
explore for players to
her huge rich environments and locales
I'm not it's set not that long after the
events of Black Flag right well we're
not in the same timeline per se but we
are set joined universe oh yeah no it's
a we're a brand new IP brand-new
universe we start you know in the early
1700s and our goal is to really allow
the players to understand the historical
setting and then start to tell their own
stories along with the world that
unfolds in front of them so in terms of
that historical setting the thing I
always loved about Ubisoft games is how
committed you are to researching that so
absolutely what's the process been like
researching pirates has been a lot of
fun yeah I mean I'm so glad I'm making a
game about pirates instead of something
like masonry or something that I have
zero interest in and being able to
research the locations where it took
place the acts the factions the
influence and it's amazing living in
Ubisoft Singapore or in Singapore it's a
country that surrounded by water it's an
island and in fact we have PI players
and and members on our team who have
pirate blood the bogus pirates are a
historical pirate we have one of our
team members who actually his ancestor
was a bogus pirate so it's really part
of our blood as part of our DNA at the
studio what kind of misconceptions about
pirates maybe from modern media have you
sort of come across and kind of wanting
to show like the real the realities of
being part um as you see in our game
it's very brutal it's it's a it's a very
intense and action-packed level of con
of combat and what we want to show is
that the entire ships themselves are
very powerful very strong these ships
during during the Age of piracy and
during the age of sail they were the
most powerful weapons on earth they
change the shape of nations and we want
players to really feel that power when
they're at the helm of their ships the
other thing is that the comical aspect
is not something that we're building it
are we want it to be a very believable
world where you feel powerful where you
feel like a predator because that's what
Pirates were then and that's really what
they are today yeah what we're saying
now is obviously the multiplayer aspects
but a lot of people have been kind of
asking for a story-driven element is
there any any of that that we can look
forward to well our game is multiplayer
always that doesn't mean that there's no
story that doesn't mean there's no
narrative we have both a systemic shared
open world where you
sail by yourself or meet up with other
players or form a gang and then go on
high sand and really terrorize a trade
routes or you can go into the pvp arenas
they're kind of arenas and basically
compete against other pirates the
narrative we built from the ground up so
the narrative is not a separate thing or
a one-off or a side thing it's
integrated into everything you do in
Skull and Bones so let's say I've read
up the game yeah how am I going to be
placed with other people are the Pirates
other factions how is that going to work
well you start out as an upstart pirate
captain in the Caribbean you leave the
Caribbean by refusing the Kings pardon
it was an act of clemency that was
offered to pirates and you head for the
southern tip of Madagascar and you
basically find out that you're not the
only fish in the sea you know you're not
the only predator and you've got to work
your way up the food chain you'll meet
other historical characters historically
inspired pirates and other players along
that journey I think that the experience
that we want to build is one more
players feel that the world is reacting
to them that they have influence over it
and that you know if you and I play we
want to be able to tell our stories of
our successes and our accomplishments is
that is it a fixed set character that
you can apply as or do you get to choose
the avatar well as you can see in the
demo there's different captain's at the
helm of each of these ships players will
be able to select from multiple captains
and once they do that they're going to
be able to personalize the captain in a
way that reflects their you know their
personality
there's also characters within our world
and you see them even on the deck of the
ship that are unique characters you have
Silva merci he is a quartermaster for
you and you have even you know up in the
crow's nest
Kenny McGill who's a 16 year old
Scottish sailor who's been basically
thrust onto your crew so you'll meet
other characters like that and develop
bonds and go on journeys with those
characters and is this crew something
customisable and you're going to find
different people across your adventure
and bring them onto your crew and you
kind of choose what roles each of these
members but it's a little early to talk
about what we want to do with our crew
and this is really just the tip of the
iceberg but you'll be able to recruit
crew you'll be able to go to taverns and
find new people for your crew but how
that affects your gameplay is still
something that is yet to be kind of
unfolded but the main thing to think
about customization is we have an RPG
archetype system
you have shipped classes and ship types
that reflect play styles that people
should be familiar with if they've ever
played an RPG so the roles that you
think about in other games whether it's
support direct damage or what I like to
play which is like long range stay stay
in the shadows there's there's those
sort sort of ship classes you know for
you so how do those ship classes relate
to kind of classes that people might be
familiar with other things like the
sloop the man of war right reggae what
you see just three of them in our in our
demo you see that like you said the
frigate which is our enforcer type and
it's a very defensive tanky ship but
also does really really high damage with
the broadsides and people are often
surprised to find out it's the fastest
ship in the game be it's not the most
accelerating ship but when you're able
to be on the high seas and you're in
pursuit and with that big giant frigate
you're going to catch people the
Brigantine is up close personal has a
devastating Ram its I stay away from it
but I definitely fear it when it comes
at me and finally my favorite which is
the sloop-of-war
this is a marksman type it has a very
effective long line a broadside and a
mortar that allows you to basically you
know do an additional damage from long
range going back a little bit to when
you said you as you're becoming a pirate
and you're becoming more and more
infamous how is that going to be
reflected in the game is it going to be
like cosmetic or is it gonna be you know
like a realm of influence that perhaps
other players can see yes so yes all
those things the biggest thing is that
when you do something in the world the
world has it has an impact it reacts I
want personally and I hope that other
people feel the same way as pirates I
want people to see my ship see my
accomplishments be afraid of me
because they can see that I've done or
accomplished things that they haven't
dreamed of I want them to be jealous of
my figurehead jealous of my sails see my
guild pattern and my pirate you know
gang flag and be scared of me and those
are things that are done through
customization and progression you talk
about this open world that the open sea
how big are we are we talking how much
of it is is explorable where can I sail
well the mode that you see in the demo
is Madagascar that's the first area that
we're exposing but you know stay tuned
in the coming months we'll talk about it
more but look at a map of the Indian
Ocean and dream because that's what
we're doing we look at it we think how
can we bring people to really end
locations that are exotic that they've
never been to in any game ever that
really reflect the age of piracy and and
all of the things that took place in
this world it's full of ton of stories
and we want to help players not only
experience stories like that but form
their own that they can tell other
people that that will you know propel
them on their own journeys you talk
about visiting taverns and stuff that
was that gonna be something that you
explore on foot as your captain or is it
going to be like a UI menu thing how is
that going to work we'll talk more in a
couple months but what we want players
to understand specifically is we have a
hideout your hideout is the basically
the linchpin of the pirate fantasy it's
where you handle your upgrades you
collect new ships you personalize and
customize those ships you meet new
characters and as well as meeting people
in the tavern and getting information
and Intel about the world before you
plan your heist there's other
opportunities for us to create that sort
of experience within the world but this
is kind of where we're at right now
we're showing people the loot hunt mode
so they can really dream about the
fantasy of being a pirate at the helm of
their ship in terms of so like if Dave
and I were going to play we'll be able
to play together on one ship or is it I
have a ship and he has ship every
captain has their own ship all right
every captain is able to customize it to
their a preference the cool thing about
it is if you guys were playing together
you could plan your synergies like okay
this ship works well with this make sure
you bring this this can in I'll bring a
mortar that will slow and stun my you
know enemy and and now let's work
together this hunt and exploit the trade
routes together those synergies we think
really add the complexity and depth and
if you look at the demo you can see that
there's a really really heavy influence
of the wind in our world and that wind
that topology on our level design allows
players to take advantage of it through
positioning and understanding the speed
of their enemy and being able to
overtake your enemy by meeting smarter
with him and using the wind it's it's a
really cool thing we're seeing even now
while people are playing it live at e3
now being a captain of a ship obviously
being at the helm of a vessel is
obviously just one of the roles that you
take you've got a Cutlass at your side
you've got a blunderbuss are we going to
see anything when it comes to like
swordplay gunplay combat or is it all
going to be shipped to ship based well
we're focused again we're focused really
on making sure people understand the
naval combat that we're trying to expose
the depth we're not black flag
in gameplay we have much deeper
complexity in terms of our combat we
have boarding boarding for us as a
high-risk high-reward maneuver you're
seeing a little taste of it in
multiplayer now and you know as we start
to release more and more about the game
you're going to find out more about
everything you can do as a pirate how
you can take over your enemies and how
you can basically put them at the tip of
your sword and at the end of your cannon
mmm one of the things I noticed in the
trailer that I'm very glad is returning
other shanties absolutely uh every
shanty that you hear in the game will be
a brand new recording we have really an
amazing tone amazing feeling the
ambience you have I think three shanties
that you can hear in all of our assets
now of the new ones as well as ones that
will unfold specifically about the
Indian Ocean and such so we're really
excited everybody loves shanties and we
want it we were really proud to be able
to bring it back to two scholar modes
when you come sorry go ahead with a
shanties that you've researched and like
actually with song of the time or if you
kind of modified and added a couple of
your own well the shanties were
primarily work songs they were designed
to you know allow the crew to have a
proper cadence let them know what type
of work need to be done and to really
invigorate the crew while they were
doing their work and that's what they
are in our game we're also exploring
ways to bring new music and tones from
the world people should feel as if
they're not listening into a soundtrack
that's outside the world but that the
world is speaking to them and shanties
are a critical part of that unification
between the captain the quartermaster
and the crew so when it comes to a
multiplayer are you going to be doing
something similar to foreigner where you
gain control of areas there's the
seasons involved in the world kind of
adapts to who's winning yes seasons are
a key part in skull and bones of our
progression to become the ultimate
pirate king kingpin you compete against
other pirates and part of that is being
able to have the right gang defeat your
enemies and really master the trade
routes against your competitors so as
you grow and you customize your ship
even further
are they purely cosmetic upgrades are
they like so if they're for example is
someone who's super good at the game you
know get all the top tier upgrades what
can newer players maybe do to combat
that or they
to the matchmaking maybe not put in the
same well I mean we will have
matchmaking so that you have the best
time possible but our PvP is horizontal
and the progression is based on choice
and and your skill
I don't want players to play and I don't
think anybody wants to play a game where
they're outgunned but just because
someone played longer than them and we
want it to be something where over time
you develop the right ship the right
configuration the right customization
for how you want to play in your play
style but it's not a vertical race in
our you know our shared systemic world
of course we're going to push you
through a progression that allows you to
meet new challenges and always have
something in front of you that's tougher
and tougher and against other players
we're going to make sure it's fair now
when obviously pirates say they had a
lot of loot on board if they've been
doing their job right and you mentioned
having a hideout is there going to be
like a risk system if your ships become
full you need to get your hideout to
stowaway loot up or hide it somewhere is
it possible for your ship to be sunk and
lose all your hard-earned gold
okay so piracy is risk versus reward and
in our world it's the same thing so
there will be opportunities for your
sail with very little risk but the
reward is not going to be the same as if
you went into a very dangerous waters
where there's other pirates who can sink
you and take your loot and that's the
experience we want we want people to be
you know just that feeling even now when
we're playing the game if you've got
your hole full of loot and you're holed
even in the mode or whether it's in the
hunting grounds when we're playing it
that feeling of at any given moment
somebody could find me put me in their
sights and sink me and take my stuff is
really really overwhelming and I'm not
the best player I think I'm good but
when I see certain guys on the dev team
I get nervous because I know their
intentions are not to come over and
high-five me they want my loot they want
my stuff what happens when you're sunk
do you have to kind of go away and lick
your wounds by another ship or like
scholar enemy vessel well we want
players to be right back in the mix and
it's important that the players have
choice in the number of ships they have
when I get sunk I you know sometimes
sulk and switch ships or whatever switch
roles or changed my roles and we want
players to constantly be feeling that
pressure of you know do I lose my do I
lose my loot now do I take my stuff back
to the hideout and you know
plan another heist that's the feeling we
want so you said that singing this is a
use of Singapore's like first first
gamers lead dev team what's that been
like because I mean you see a lot of the
other studios like kind of okay we are
taking this one this is our one so
what's it like to finally get out there
I mean first of all it's amazing
we've been in Singapore for about eight
years Singapore is that the center of
the technology you know racing in in
Southeast Asia and that kind of reflects
our studio we have people from over 30
countries English is our common language
well you got dozens of languages spoke
in the studio and you have a huge
connection between all of these
developers from different backgrounds
working within the same vision of
bringing this game to life and it's so
exciting like I saw pictures and videos
of our reveal after the fact and it's
just amazing to see everybody react the
way that they did so we're all super
proud one thing that was a little
surprising you talked a lot about the
research and it's very grounded in
reality but then in the end we see a
rather large squid a Kraken yeah I'm at
the time you know first of all sailors
believed in all sorts of stuff and one
of the things that they feared most was
things like the Kraken and our world
reflects the sensibility of the sailors
of the day and the pirates of the day if
you look at maps from the 14th through
17th century there's things in the
corner of the map that the sailors
saying don't go there that there's
danger you know and that's that feeling
we want we want players to be totally
afraid of that type of creature
appearing out of nowhere and pulling
them under you're already playing
towards not both the history and the
reality of pirates but also their
superstitions absolutely the world is
seen through the eyes of the pirates of
the day and that's how we want you to
feel we want you to you know to take a
little journey with us to the Golden Age
of piracy in the Indian Ocean and really
feel like you're in a world that
responds and reacts to everything that
happens and it's a real place so you
said the people getting the hands on it
on the show floor they're going to be
beaches that people can sign up for yeah
absolutely we have live phases that are
coming soon you can register for that at
Skull and Bones game.com and for us we
are a pirate crew and our community is
going to be built on people who want to
have the ultimate pirate game we don't
want to leave anybody behind your voice
is important so if you you know you
register if you guys want to play please
register now and and be a part of it we
want to shape it and make it the
ultimate pirate experience awesome
Justin thank you so much really excited
to play the game
yeah well come by the booth and play oh
yeah also things like you alright
guys for more from e3 2017 make sure you
don't go anywhere I keep your eyes
peeled to GameSpot